كيف يكتب رواد الفضاء ملاحظاتهم الامر ليس
سهلا كما تتصورون لان الاقلام التي
نستخدمها في حياتنا اليوميه لا تعمل في
الفضاء اذا كيف يكتبون منذ مغادره البشر
سطح الارض نحو الفضاء الخارجي للمره
الاولى في ستينات القرن الماضي اكتشف رواه
الفضاء ان اقلام الحبر الجاف لم تكن فعاله
فالحبر يحتاج للجاذبيه كي يستخدم بالكتابه
لذا تم التفكير في اقلام الرصاص لكن تبين
بعد البحث انه مصنوع من ماده الجرافيت
القابله للاشتعال وهذا قد يمثل خطوره على
رواد الفضاء ومحطه الفضاء الدوليه موقع
كشف ان القلم المستخدم في الفضاء حتى
اليوم هو قلم يحمل اسم فيتشر نسبه الى
المخترع الذي ابتكره عام
1965 هذا القلم لا يعتمد على الجاذبيه
للحصول على تدفق الحبر فهو يستخدم تقنيه
ضغط عبوه الحبر بالنيتروجين الذي يدفع
الحبر نحو راس القلم المصنوع من كره
معدنيه